Olha que pergunta mais curiosa. Doutor,
fui orientado a não comer mais vegetais
por conta dos antinutrientes. Tem como
eliminar? Olha só, pessoal, hoje eu vou
bater um papo com vocês sobre um assunto
que tem causado muita confusão. Sabe
quando você tá lá de boa comendo a sua
saladinha, achando que tá arrasando a
dieta saudável e de repente alguém chega
e fala que você não deveria comer
vegetais por causa dos antinutrientes?
Pois é, vamos destrinchar essa história
toda hoje porque tem muita informação
desencontrada circulando por aí. Deixa
eu começar contando uma coisa que muita
gente não sabe. As plantas coitadas não
podem sair correndo quando um predador
aparece, né? Então elas envolveram suas
próprias estratégias de defesa ao longo
de milhões de anos de evolução. É como
se fosse um sistema de segurança natural
delas. En contra alguns animais têm
espinhos ou cascas duras, as plantas
criaram compostos químicos para se
proteger. Esses compostos, meus amigos,
são os famosos antinutrientes. É
basicamente a planta dizendo assim: "Ó,
pode até me comer, mas vai ter que ralar
um pouquinho para digerir." Os
antinutrientes são substâncias naturais
presentes principalmente em alimentos de
origem vegetal. Eles interferem na
absorção dos nutrientes pelo nosso
organismo. E os principais vilões, ou
melhor personagens dessa história são os
fitatos, que adoram se grudar no ferro e
no zinco, dificultando a absorção. Tem
também os oxalatos, aqueles danadinhos
que se ligam ao cálcio, as lectinas que
podem irritar o intestino e os taninos
que dão aquela sensação de boca seca
quando você come caca verde, lembra?
Então, esses compostos estão em toda
parte, seja no feijão, nas lentilhas, no
espinafre, nas nozes, nos cereais
integrais, praticamente todos os
vegetais t algum tipo de antinutriente.
Esse conceito de antinutriente se tornou
popular a partir do livro do Dr. Steven
Gandrey, O paradoxo dos vegetais. Eu
admiro e respeito muito o trabalho desse
pesquisador, porém tem várias ressalvas
que eu preciso explicar para vocês sobre
essa teoria. Não devemos entrar em
pânico e jogar todos os vegetais no
lixo. A medicina funcional tem uma visão
bem equilibrada sobre isso. Como sempre
digo os meus pacientes, o problema não é
o alimento em si, mas como a gente
prepara ele. Nossos ancestrais já sabiam
disso intuitivamente.
Por que você acha que a sua avó sempre
deixava o feijão de molho de um dia pro
outro? Não era frescura, não era
sabedoria popular baseada em observação
prática.
O processo de molhar é fantástico.
Quando você deixa leguminoso como
feijão, grão de bico e lentilha de molho
por umas 12 horas, você consegue reduzir
significativamente os antinutrientes.
Estudos mostram que isso pode diminuir
as lectinas em até 50%, os taníos em até
25% e os inibidores de proteas em até
30%. É uma diferença brutal. E o mais
legal é que é super simples de fazer.
Coloca os grãos numa tivela com água.
Deixa na geladeira durante a noite,
troca a água umas duas vezes se der e
pronto. No dia seguinte joga fora essa
água do remolho que tá cheia de
antinutrientes dissolvidos e cozinha com
água nova. Agora o cozimento também é
nosso grande aliado nessa história. O
calor quebra muitas dessas moléculas
chatinhas. Por exemplo, o oxalato de
cálcio presente nas verduras pode ser
reduzido em até 90% depois do cozimento.
90%, gente, é muita coisa. Então aquele
espinafre refogadinho tá muito mais
biodisponível do que o cru da salada. E
tem um truque massa que eu aprendi
estudando medicina funcional. Temperar
os vegetais com limão ou vinagre depois
de cozinhar ajuda a diminuir ainda mais
os fitatos e oxalatos. Além de ficar uma
delícia, né? A fermentação é outro
processo incrível. Pensa no chucurute,
no quinchi, no kefir. Durante a
fermentação, as bactérias do bem
literalmente comem esses antinutrientes,
transformando o alimento em algo muito
mais digerível e nutritivo. E a
germinação. Então, quando você germina
sementes, grãos e leguminosas, você
ativa enzimas que neutralizam grande
parte dos antinutrientes. É como se você
acordasse a semente e ela começasse a se
preparar para virar planta, largando
todas as defesas químicas. Mas olha que
interessante, nem tudo são flores, mas
também nem tudo são espinhos. Os
antinutrientes não são 100% do mal. Na
verdade, muitos deles têm propriedades
benéficas comprovadas pela ciência. Os
fitatos, por exemplo, são antioxidantes
poderosos. Eles podem ajudar a prevenir
a formação de radicais livres e até
contribuir pro controle da glicemia. As
saponinas estimulam o sistema de defesa
imune e podem reduzir o colesterol ruim.
As lectinas, quando em quantidades
adequadas, estão associadas à redução do
risco de doenças cardiovasculares e
diabetes. É aquele conceito de medicina
funcional que eu sempre falo, a dose é
que faz o veneno. A questão toda é que a
medicina funcional não trabalha com
extremos, não é sobre eliminar
completamente os vegetais da dieta, pelo
contrário. Então, os vegetais são
fundamentais pro nosso organismo. tem
fibras, vitaminas, minerais,
fitonutrientes, compostos bioativos que
regulam nossa expressão gênica e nossa
epigenética. Como eu costumo dizer,
comida não é só caloria, é informação
pro nosso corpo. E os vegetais carregam
informações valiosíssimas. O problema
surge quando a pessoa tem um intestino
já comprometido, tem uma disbiose severa
ou pode ter uma síndrome intestino
irritável ou alguma condição autoimune.
Nesses casos específicos, pode ser
interessante fazer uma dieta de
eliminação temporária como protocolo
gaps ou uma dieta tipo low fod map,
sempre com acompanhamento profissional.
Mas isso é tratamento, não é pra vida
toda. A ideia é recuperação de
intestinal e depois reintroduzir os
alimentos gradualmente.
Inclusive tem pessoas que se beneficiam
fazendo dieta carnívora, comendo
basicamente músculos e víceras de
animais. Pode parecer estranho, mas
ajuda em muitos casos de doenças
autoimunes, apesar de ser uma dieta de
muito difícil sustentação pra vida
inteira, mas pode ser uma estratégia
muito útil por alguns meses ou poucos
anos em casos específicos. Não deixe de
assistir meus vídeos antigos sobre esse
assunto. Basta pesquisar aí dentro da
plataforma do YouTube com o meu nome e a
palavra dieta carnívor que você acha.
Então, cada caso é um caso. A gente
nunca deve generalizar que algo é sempre
bom e é sempre bom para todos. Tem gente
que me pergunta: "Mas, doutor, e os
vegetarianos e veganos como ficam? Eles
realmente precisam ter mais atenção com
o preparo dos alimentos, já que a dieta
deles é baseada em vegetais. Mas com as
técnicas certas de preparo, dá para ter
uma alimentação plant based super
nutritiva. O segredo tá em variar
bastante os alimentos, combinar
diferentes fontes de proteínas vegetais
e caprichar no preparo. E olha, tem
muita gente vegetariana e vegana por aí
com sal de ferro.
Ara que o nosso corpo é uma máquina
incrível de adaptação. Populações que
tradicionalmente consomem muitos grãos e
leguminosas desenvolveram até adaptações
genéticas para lidar melhor com esses
antinutrientes. E nossa microbiota
intestinal também se adapta. Quanto mais
diversificada for a alimentação, mais
diversificada vai ser a sua microbiota e
melhor ela vai lidar com diferentes
tipos e compostos dos alimentos. Então,
respondendo a pergunta inicial, você foi
orientado a não comer mais vegetais por
causa dos antinutrientes?
Tem como eliminar? Você tem basicamente
duas estratégias. Ou você tenta fazer a
dieta carnívoro, que lembrando, não é só
comer músculos, bifes, né? Tem que comer
também víceras. E tem também uma outra
alternativa e é bem mais simples do que
parece. Demolhar, cozinhar, fermentar,
germinar, combinar com alimentos ácidos.
São teclas milenares que nossos
ancestrais já utilizavam e que a ciência
moderna comprovou a eficácia. O que a
medicina funcional propõe é uma
alimentação consciente, onde você
entende o que tá comendo e como preparar
os alimentos para extrair o máximo dos
nutrientes. É sobre personalização
também. Cada pessoa é única com sua
genética, seu microbioma, seu histórico
de saúde. O que funciona para um pode
não funcionar para outro. Por isso a
importância de acompanhamento
personalizado, individualizado com
médico e nutricionista. Para finalizar
nosso papo, eu quero deixar bem claro
que os vegetais são nossos aliados, não
nossos inimigos. Os antinutrientes, sim,
existem, mas temos ferramentas simples e
eficazes para lidar com eles. É questão
de conhecimento prática. Não precisa ter
medo de comer vegetais, precisa é saber
prepará-los. E olha, depois que você
pega o jeito, vira a rotina. Deixar o
feijão de molho, refogar o espinafre,
fazer um chucrurute caseiro. Tudo isso
pode fazer parte naturalmente do seu dia
a dia. Sua saúde agradece, seu intestino
agradece e seu paladar também, porque
comida bem preparada é muito mais
gostosa. Então, bora lá, continuar
comendo seus vegetais, mas agora com a
sabedoria de como prepará-los da melhor
forma possível. Esse é o caminho da
medicina funcional, do equilíbrio, do
conhecimento e da personalização. Até a
próxima, pessoal.